The verdict forms are complete.
I will now publish them.
They read as follows
In the Circuit Court
of the 17th Judicial Circuit in and four
Broward County, Florida.
Case number 19 7166 S.F.
Ten a state of Florida
plaintiff versus Scot Peterson defendant
verdict count one.
We the jury find as follows
as to the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
or four Lauderdale Broward County Florida
verdict count two
we the jury find as follows
as to the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale
Broward County, Florida
verdict count three.
We the jury find as follows
as the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale, Broward County, Fort
Verdict count four.
We the
jury find as follows as the defendant
in this case the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale,
Broward County, Florida.
Verdict count five.
We the jury find as follows
as to the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So saying
we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale
Broward County, Florida
verdict count six
we the jury find as follows
as to the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale,
Broward County Florida
verdict count seven.
We the jury find as follows
as to the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale, Broward
County, Florida,
verdict count eight.
We the jury find as follows
as the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale, Broward County for
verdict count nine.
We the jury find as follows
as the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale,
Broward County, Florida,
verdict count ten.
We the jury find as follows
as to the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this 29th day of June 2023
at Fort Lauderdale,
Broward County, Florida,
verdict count 11.
We the jury find as follows
ask if the defendant in this case
the defendant is not guilty.
So say we all this time saved you in 2023
at Fort Lauderdale, Broward
County, Florida.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'm
going to address
you only by the numbers
that are on the back of your badges.
Juror number one,
are these your true verdicts?
Yes, they are.
Juror number two.
Are these your true verdicts? Yes.
Juror number four,
are these your true verdicts? Yes.
Juror number five
Juror number six,
are these your true verdicts? Yes.
Juror number seven,
are these your true verdicts?
Ladies and gentlemen,
I wish to thank you for your time
and consideration of this case.
I also wish to advise you
of some very special privileges
enjoyed by jurors.
No juror can ever be required
to talk about
the discussions
that occurred in the jury room
except by court order.
For many centuries,
our society has relied upon juries
for consideration of difficult cases.
We have recognized for hundreds of years
that a jury's deliberations, discussions
and votes
should remain their private affair
as long as they wish it.
Therefore,
the law gives you a unique privilege
not to speak about the jury's work,
although you were at liberty
to speak with anyone
about your deliberations.
You are also at liberty
to refuse to speak to anyone
and request to discuss either
your verdict
or your deliberations may come from those
who are simply curious,
from those who might seek
to find fault with you.
From the media,
from the attorneys, or elsewhere,
it will be up to each of you
to decide whether to preserve your
privacy as a juror.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I want
to again
give you my sincere
thanks for your time, effort and energy.
99% of the citizens
that live in Broward County,
a county of 2 million, have no idea
what happens
when you're actually selected on jury
and you actually serve
through the process.
But now you all know
and I know most people
don't say thank you,
but I will say thank you
because I know the time, effort
and energy that went into this.
I have a
thank you letter and certificate.
I'm going to give that to the court
deputy who's going to pass that out
when they walk you out
because it has your names on them.
The reason I normally do this
in person in the courtroom,
but I'm not going to do it
today, is because
I'm not
and have not addressed you by your name.
That's why we use the numbers
in care of your privacy.
I did also want to let you all know
I will be entering an order today
that instructs the clerk of court,
the trial court
administrator, as well as both parties
not to disclose your names. Okay.
So the only way
your names are going to be
disclosed is if you choose,
and you certainly may choose.
So if you want to go out there
and talk to whoever you want to talk to.
You're perfectly entitled to do that.
If you want to go out there
and never talk to another human
being about this ever again.
You're perfectly entitled
to do that, too.
I want to emphasize that it's
each of your decisions to make.
But momentarily,
I'm going to have you step in the back
and collect your belongings.
The court's deputies are going to walk
you out to your cars,
and that's going
to conclude your jury service.
I do have two quick
pieces of bad news for you.
Number one,
I'm going to need those lanyards back.
So if you take them off
and just put them on the ledge
in front of you,
we'll collect them from you.
Number two,
since you actually did serve on a jury,
they will not summon
you for jury duty
for a year, for 12 months
So I'll see you next year.
Okay.
All right.
Unless you all have any questions for me,
ladies and gentlemen,
your jury services
concluded at this point again
with my great thanks for your time.
Effort and energy, madam, for Jeffrey.
There are certificates for each.
Your jury service is concluded
and you are dismissed.
We've been watching
some profoundly emotional moments
in a Fort Lauderdale courtroom.
Scot Peterson,
the school resource officer
who was there
the day of the Parkland shooting.
Acquitted of all 11 charges he was facing
including felony child neglect,
felony child neglect,
leading to bodily harm on seven counts.
Culpable negligence
on three counts and perjury
in a single count.
He broke down in tears,
clasping his hands together,
looking skyward,
thanking and embracing his attorney,
who also is
apparently emotional in the courtroom.
We saw parents of Parkland victims
sitting inside the courtroom,
shaking their heads,
visibly upset over this decision.
He was facing 95 and a half years
in prison.
But tonight, he will go home.
A free man.
The actions of this officer
are more than five years ago.
Really stunned and perplexed
the parents of the victims that day.
One asking, what was he doing?
He spent this time outside
of the building
where the shooting was taking place,
did not act.
And today we learn
he is found not guilty
on all charges
in the deaths of Carol Lofgren, walking
Oliver, Jamie Guttenberg,
Scott Beagle, Meadow Pollack
and in the injuries of Anthony Burgess,
Kyle Leman
and Marion Colbert Franco
as well as Stacey Lipo.
Those are the names
of some of the victims
and we are seeing them here today
on our screens.
I do want to go ahead
and bring in Josh Campbell.
He was there reporting that day
Josh,
was this what you were expecting
as we had gone
into this third day of deliberations,
You know, some of these trials
as they occur,
you tend to be able to predict
what's going to happen.
I can be honest,
talking to law enforcement
officials, those
who have been watching this
no one really knew
because of how rare this prosecution was.
I mean, you have to remember the officer
here,
the former officer wasn't accused
of doing something,
of committing some type of overt crime.
He was accused of
not doing a failing to act.
The prosecutors here had prosecuted him
under a statute
that referred to him as a caregiver
under Florida law,
which means that he had a duty
to protect
those children,
the staff that were there
at the school that day in Parkland.
Now, his attorney actually issued a quote
that was very direct,
but obviously raised
a lot of eyebrows, saying that his client
had no duty to protect the victims.
Now, for his part,
all along as this prosecution
and the investigation was underway,
what Peterson said is that
he didn't react because he couldn't tell
where the gunshots were coming from.
Of course, at the end of the day,
No one knows what was happening
inside his head.
I mean, I've been in situations
where you have
if you have gunfire,
particularly
if it's bouncing off buildings,
you might not be able to direct yourself.
But to that location.
But what prosecutors said is
he didn't even stop
to ask the fleeing students,
what did you see?
And again,
as the person who was there on that day
who could have responded
that's why
this prosecution was brought,
because he did not act, prosecutors said.
But as we just learn for ourselves
in this very dramatic
reading there of the jury's verdict,
not guilty on all counts.
Now, of course,
for the families of the survivors
or excuse me,
for those who were who died
that day at Parkland,
this is obviously going to be
something that's very difficult for them
to move forward with.
The person who was there,
who was trained, who had that background,
who could have reacted did not act.
But, of course, of this jury
deciding that Peterson, of course,
should not face
any criminal liability for that.
Final point,
I will say,
is that
although and again,
this is going to give no comfort
to the surviving family
members of the Parkland victims,
this was a case
that reverberated across
law enforcement circles
around the country.
Putting law enforcement
essentially on notice
to include school resource officers,
that if you fail to act,
there are prosecutors out there
who will attempt to bring charges.
So although Peterson obviously was found
not guilty,
you can imagine that
there must have been
some type of behavior
change across the country
putting these people on notice
that if you're the person who gets paid
to protect this building,
to protect these people,
and you fail to act, you
you may at the very least
face prosecution.